Allow me to tell you the classic
children's tale of chicken,
little otherwise known as henny penny as
the tale goes.
Little Henny was outside one day when an
acorn fell from a tree and hit her on
the head because of her naive,
a Tay and simple mindedness.
Henny foolishly began to believe that
the sky itself was falling down around
her.
She spent the rest of the day trying to
convince others like Goosey loosey and
Turkey lurky that the sky was most
certainly falling in.
The world was surely coming to an end in
most versions of the story.
The trip does not end well for Henny and
her hysterical friends after they meet
the sly foxy.
I don't want to give everything away
though,
so either read the story for yourself or
check out the classic season six episode
of the Golden Girls in which they
reenact the tail.
I mentioned Hani and Lucy and Turkey and
foxy.
Not just because they're great names to
say,
but because it seems that just about
everyone is telling us the sky is
falling these days between trump,
Russia and North Korea.
We've got about half the country that's
in total freakout mode everyday.
This freak out takes on a new urgency.
One day the world is ending because
America left the Paris climate accord
and another day it's because of the net
neutrality reversal and another day it's
because trump holds his water glass with
two hands.
This endless hysteria is not only being
amplified by the media,
but it's actually being poked and
prodded by them as well.
Blue check,
verify journalists on twitter who worked
for news organizations which really are
nothing more than partisan activist
outlets want to keep you clicking on
their articles and videos and they know
that the best way to do that is to
convince you that not only is the sky
falling,
but it's gonna land directly on your
head.
What F and just hear me out on this one.
This outrage factory is completely wrong
and the world isn't coming to an end
just yet crazy.
I know,
but I think that it actually might be
true.
This doesn't mean that things are
perfect,
but they are pretty damn good.
This is the position of my guest this
week,
Harvard psychology professor Steven
Pinker pinker argues,
despite our world of perceived horror
and chaos,
people are living longer,
happier,
healthier,
and freer lives right now,
more than any other time in human
history.
This doesn't mean we don't have work to
do,
but if we don't stop and smell the
roses,
we might toss away all the goodness
humans have created for the prospect of
a utopia that will never appear.
This is why I'm so proud of the work
we've done here on the Rubin report.
I truly believed that the conversations
we're having are at least some part of
the antidote to the craziness right now.
If those of us who care about
enlightenment principles like science
reason and natural rights can make our
voices louder than this cliff,
we seem to be about to go off of,
might just turn into a bridge to a
better world.
Henny penny story took a drastic turn
when she met Foxy Lacasse who tricked
her and her friends to go to his layer.
Well,
in real life,
we've got a wolf blitzer in a situation
room.
If the sky is falling,
maybe just changing the channel is all
we have to do to survive the day.
Joining me today is a johnstone family
professor in the Department of
Psychology at Harvard University as well
as the New York Times bestselling author
whose new book enlightenment now is for
sale right now,
Steven Pinker,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you.
I am.
I am thrilled to have you here.
I think I have emailed or called or
contacted or pigeon messaged everyone
related to you or do that knows you in
any way to get you here and here I am
and here you are.
Worked.
It goes to prove that a little
positivity I think can make some things
happen.
So true.
Yeah.
Alright.
A lot of want to talk to you about.
I thought before we dive into the book
and all the things that you teach and
write about and all that.
I just,
I like hearing a little bit about
people's history and where they come
from and growing up and all that.
You are Canadian and I've had a lot of
Canadians on lately.
I find there's something about Canadians
in general that I like.
What is it about Canadians that leads to
a certain pleasant disposition?
Well,
it was so reasonable or so.
Yeah.
I liked her.
Sometimes people say the motto of
candidates,
Peace Order and good government.
Uh,
and uh,
it's a country that is,
that has been diverse for quite some
time.
A Quebec where I grew up has a English
speaking community in a French speaking
community.
And uh,
we've,
we,
we didn't begin with a revolution like
the United States from negotiated our
way to independence.
Uh,
we're part of the British empire and the
British Commonwealth and kind of have
that British reserve and a politeness.
Yeah.
So that we have,
we have some things going for us.
A couple of things going for it.
Yeah.
At least until at least the,
all the Americans end up moving up there
if things keep going this way.
Although we might build a wall,
you guys may end up building the wall.
Exactly.
Um,
tell me a little bit about growing up,
your family,
what,
what kind of family you grew up in.
Um,
I grew up in the English speaking a
section of Montreal in Montreal.
It was pretty segregated when I grew up.
I grew up in a,
um,
the,
uh,
Jewish,
English speaking community,
uh,
which was known for producing among
others,
Leonard Cohen,
who was a contemporary of my mother's a,
the authored Mordecai richler who was a
contemporary of my father's a William
Shatner,
burt Bacharach.
Wow.
Um,
the,
um,
uh,
saul bellow,
spare,
disperse his childhood in Montreal.
So it's a small community that has a
number of people that we're proud of.
Yeah.
What do you make of that,
that,
that so many.
I mean,
that's a pretty diverse,
interesting group of people right there.
And I'm sure there are others.
Uh,
yeah,
I,
uh,
it,
it may just be that I'm having many
cultural influences,
both candidates really dominated by the
United States.
It really is the 800 pound gorilla next
door.
So it's the American influence,
the British influence,
the French influence.
Perhaps it's just being in a
cosmopolitan diverse community that
helped with that.
And,
and of course,
the,
uh,
the Jewish influence,
although it was not,
um,
I didn't grow up in.
None of the people that I mentioned grew
up in an ultra orthodox community.
I grew up in a room with a reform
temple.
Uh,
we didn't take God all that seriously,
but we did take Jewish identity
seriously.
Yeah.
I don't remember a moment in which I
decided,
oh,
I'm an atheist.
I just was not a big issue one way or
another.
Do you find that to be sort of standard
thing with most secular Jews?
I think that's sort of at least the ones
that I had been talking to on this show
that I think are sort of out there more.
That seems to be a thing that there's an
ethnic identity or a cultural identity
that's separate from the belief part.
Absolutely.
I think that's more true of Judaism than
it is,
say Catholicism where the belief really
is stipulated in Judaism,
isn't a bit of a kind of don't ask,
don't tell as long as you want,
painful.
As long as we made the laws and rituals,
if you keep the sabbath,
if you have,
you know,
Mazzoni on Passover and then you're a
good Jew and what you believe is just
not as important.
One a rabbi said to my wife Rebecca
Goldstein,
another secular Jew,
well known,
uh,
a secular humanist writer,
when she talked about her novel,
36 arguments for the existence of God,
a work of fiction,
which is kind of the.
And she spoke at a Jewish community
center and that was a little worried
whether there'd be some pushback from
the rabbi who introduced her and
afterwards he went over and he said,
you know,
it's not like in Judaism it says you
have to believe in God.
You just can't believe that more than
one of them.
That's,
I mean,
that's pretty perfect.
Do you think there's a,
there's an inherent problem there sort
of disconnecting God from even if it
really is as well,
just for the longevity of it,
let's say.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
It's,
uh,
it's a good question.
I think that may have been part of the
explanation for why.
I mean there's so many secular Jewish
intellectuals kind of immersed in
argument disputation,
particularly about morals and ethics,
but without a bit,
but it was all argument disputation.
It wasn't a a,
a catechism that you had to recite.
It wasn't a set of beliefs that you have
to have.
So there was a tradition of disputation.
That's what the rabbis were famous for,
that the pill pool,
the hair splitting and,
and maybe that was a con contributor as
well,
but I went to public schools and in fact
when you go to public schools in Quebec,
when,
I mean my childhood meant you went to
Protestant schools because it was
divided along religious lines.
There were Protestant schools and
Catholic.
Oh,
interesting.
Protestant meant on Catholic.
Basically everyone else,
including the Muslims and the Jews and
Chinese and so on.
It was a bizarre system.
Yeah.
How interesting.
Happily unconstitutional in this
country.
And I got,
I got.
I actually got a pretty serious
Protestant religious education.
I saying hymns,
we said the Lord's prayer every day.
I learned about life of Jesus.
So they had the Jews and the Muslims and
everyone was getting a Protestant
schools.
Yeah.
And at one point I remember I was,
I think it was,
you know,
eight or nine and I actually,
we didn't even belong to a temple.
I said to my mother,
one of my friends said that,
that Jews aren't supposed to believe in
Jesus my should I not believe in Jesus
anymore.
She sent me to Hebrew school so fast
that made my head spin hilarious.
My teachers,
because they couldn't hire Catholic
teachers either.
Uh,
and virtually everyone in Quebec is
among the Francophone community are
Catholics.
So they actually hired Algerian and
Tunisian and Moroccan Jews to teach
French to the,
uh,
Jewish and Protestant kids in Montreal.
The Protestant kids in Montreal did not
learn French from Native Quebecois.
We looked at from a Egyptian or Tunisian
immigrants.
How bizarre it was.
I'm pretty sure I know the subject of
your next book.
I mean,
it sounds like there's just so much
richness to adjusting that,
or at least there's a little,
a little comedy in there.
Like,
it sounds like your family was kinda on
the intellectual side,
or at least at the county he was in red
house,
was full of books and magazines.
My,
uh,
my father was,
um,
had a law degree but didn't practice
when I was a child.
He was a and handled some little bit of
real estate and did a sales,
uh,
before,
starting a law practice pretty late in
life.
My mother was like most mothers of the
fifties and sixties,
a homemaker,
but then found a career when she was
getting bored,
uh,
when I became a guidance counselor and
then the vice principal of high school
and my mother were Roslyn pinker,
very intellectual and intense reader
knows everything.
A intellectually very engaged.
Yeah.
And my sister,
Susan is a,
uh,
I'm a columnist for the Wall Street
Journal,
is written in a couple of books on one
on sex differences,
one on a face to face contact.
My brother Rob,
who I worked for the Canadian government
for several decades as a policy analyst
and a,
uh,
an administrator.
So how much of the intellectual pursuits
that you all have,
do you think is his biological versus
just learned experience?
Yeah.
This is one of the themes that keeps
coming up around these decisions.
And,
and it,
it is a,
was a topic of my book,
the blank slate in the modern denial of
human nature.
The blank slate being the metaphor that
I argued became dominant and
intellectual life largely for political
reasons.
Can you explain that a little bit for
the people that,
that don't know the book?
Yeah.
So the,
the blank slate,
the modern denial of human nature just
was released in 2016 with an afterword
was about the idea that,
uh,
that there is no such thing as human
nature,
that we are blank slates written on by
our parents,
my,
by the culture,
by a education and that there's no
innate human traits or ways of learning
and thinking it's,
it's a,
you can program a human however you
want.
Uh,
and uh,
I argued that it was popular in the 20th
century for political reasons.
One of them being that it seems like the
ultimate way to achieve equality,
you know,
if we all,
if we're all zero,
then you know,
zero equals zero equals zero.
So we all have to be equal,
right?
I already,
this is a mistake in the book that
equality is really a legal and moral
principle to treat everyone equally.
It's not really the belief that we're
all clones were on blank slates and a
lot of the book try to both layout the
science of human nature,
but also to explore the political and
emotional and moral baggage and coloring
and to try to clarify it.
And so the difference between equality
of treatment and the equality of,
uh,
of,
of our biological endowment was a major
thing that also of course enters into
discussion of sex differences where one
of the reasons that certain intellectual
factions,
certain parts of feminism wants to deny
that there any sex differences.
So I think,
well that will make it impossible to
discriminate because there's nothing to
discriminate.
We're all exactly the sport exactly the
same.
And I get that big,
big mistake.
There's first of all,
there is a lot of evidence that men and
women aren't identical and all traits.
I mean,
I'm not a scientist,
but I think there is a lot of evidence.
Agree.
Yeah.
I think anyone who's had a son and a
daughter who has been in a heterosexual
relationship,
anyone who's listened to gossip about
anyone talking about anyone else.
Yeah.
Men and women are really not,
not exactly the same,
but I think the myth that at the same
was introduced for political purposes,
namely that would make discrimination
irrational,
right?
Because there's nothing to discriminate
on.
And I argue that,
that,
you know,
that's just a error in logic.
Uh,
I strongly believe in,
in gender equity that no one should be
prejudged because they're a man or a
woman,
partly because of a scientific fact that
there's huge overlap between the sexes
in any trade you want to look at.
So you can predict an individual's
traits just knowing that they're a man
or a woman,
but they,
the policy,
we should be fair.
It doesn't require the false belief that
were the same,
that are distinguishable.
What's the best?
Have you heard any argument for that
belief that you thought made any sense
or you just were which belief for the
idea that,
that this,
that these genders are equal?
Like when you must hear this from other
academics,
right?
I mean,
we know that some of this stuff is being
taught at schools.
Yeah.
Well,
there are,
you know,
there's no doubt that there are,
there's enormous,
enormous overlap.
Um,
there's no doubt.
And,
and some of the differences between the
sexes are,
are pretty small and subtle.
So in say,
mathematical ability,
which was one of the most controversial,
uh,
claims about sex differences or it could
lead to a huge firestorm when Larry
Summers,
the president of Harvard mentioned that
differences between the sexes might
explain why the number of engineering
professors at Harvard and mit wasn't 50
slash 50 down the line.
Male,
female.
This is very much like the James divorce
situation with,
with Google.
It is,
is exactly.
I mean,
it's almost,
it's almost a replay and uh,
and,
and it isn't easy.
In fact,
it would be hard to say that men or
women are better at math in general.
It's you have to even drill down to
certain subcomponents like mentally
rotating three dimensional objects that
men are clearly better at,
but women are better at,
at our word,
problems in arithmetic and math.
So it's a.
So some of the pushback is that in fact
the science is often complicated.
You can't make a sweeping across the
board generalization and then the other
kind of push back for people who defend
the blank slate as well.
Yeah,
that's true of 2002 when your book came
out,
but a society is changing and uh,
you know,
more women are,
are consuming porn and more women are
having multiple sexual partners and
maybe the differences saying sexuality,
uh,
are due to human nature,
but just due to our culture at a
particular moment that may become
obsolete.
And that seems incredibly dangerous to
me to view it that way.
Well,
maybe,
um,
although,
you know,
you could,
in some ways it's actually highway a
progressive and even correct because you
could have said,
you know,
70 years ago a women don't want to go
into the professions.
They,
they,
they want to stay home with the kids.
And Housework,
and that's what makes them complete and
satisfied and happy and there'll be all
a neurotic and anxious if they start to
become lawyers and doctors.
And we know from the course of history
that,
you know,
that's not true.
In fact,
I went as soon as the doors open,
women did pour through the doors.
Um,
and so that would be an example.
Were too strong a claim of biological
differences would have been refuted by,
by the facts of history.
So it's not a slam dunk.
I mean,
it is something that has to be examined
on a case by case basis.
Are you shocked at how difficult it is
to talk about all of this without
getting yourself yourself or,
or any of the people that talk about it
into hot water?
Yeah.
Nuance that you have to go through here.
As I can see,
you're,
you're quite well versed that you're
probably the best at it.
It's a lot to make sure that somebody
can pinpoint that one line that then
they're going to just drag you for.
Exactly.
Right.
Well,
and the reason that I wrote the blank
slate was it wasn't so much,
it's a chapter on gender,
but the point wasn't just to review the
literature on gender differences.
It was also to say,
okay,
so what,
how does it matter for our public
debates?
And I also documented in the book how
even when the book first came out,
there was a history of people being deep
platformed and it down and called know
all kinds of nasty names,
um,
for,
for the view that we're not blank
slates.
And I said,
well look,
this is based on emotion based on bad
politics,
not based on the facts.
So I kind of,
I don't know if I want to say defended
myself,
but I laid out all of these political
controversies.
So I wasn't blundering into it.
Naive.
I was actually,
that was actually the subject of the
book sometimes though,
that that can't fully defend you.
And in fact both Larry Summers and Jamie
to more,
they almost could have taken their
speeches and in case in the case of
Larry Summers,
partly did from the chapter on gender in
the book.
So I managed to escape some trouble that
people who have been repeated the
arguments got into trouble for.
Yeah.
So it's interesting.
You sort of laid out a case beforehand
to,
to defend yourself.
You did like sort of a preemptive
strike.
Exactly where someone,
both of those guys.
I know James,
I know James personally and he's been in
here.
Whereas like he sort of stumbled into
this thing and then the reaction,
the way it sort of,
it just becomes this bigger beast that
you end up fighting when you were just
really trying to talk about science.
Well the science,
I,
I wasn't just talking about the science
because I was talking about first the
science.
Then what are the political and moral
implications,
which I thought got confused feeding
back on people trying to shoehorn the
science into a politically correct
position because they were kind of lazy
when it came to the politics.
I don't believe in obviously I don't
believe in discrimination against
anyone.
Uh,
and,
but the point being that having that
belief doesn't mean that you have to
insist that were blank slates.
And I made that argument for other
controversies around human nature,
like,
do we have any violent,
uh,
impulses where there's,
there,
there's a kind of political argument for
different reasons.
And then people think,
well,
if we're innately violent,
then we're kind of doomed to war for
forever.
And if you try to reduce war,
you're just some romantic piece neck and
it's hopeless and more as in human
nature.
Therefore,
since war is bad,
uh,
and if we're violent,
then we'll always have war.
We can't be violent.
And I invest is a logical.
We do have violent impulses.
I think that's pretty clear,
but it's not all we have.
We also have a,
have the faculty of self control.
We also have empathy.
We have cognitive processes of problem
solving,
uh,
so we can figure out how we can reduce
war.
We've got moral norms.
There are just certain things you don't
do.
And the fact that part of us as violent
doesn't mean we're doomed to violence
because part of us pushes back on the
fire.
Once I cited a statistic that three
quarters of men and 60 percent of women
at least once it had a homicidal
fantasy,
imagined killing someone.
They don't like three quarters of men
and 60 percent of task.
Yeah.
And uh,
and,
and when I,
uh,
I introduced this factor electronic and
I say,
well,
what does this tell us about human
nature tells us that three quarters of
men are liars,
but,
uh,
but I pointed out this,
this doesn't mean that trying to
increase piece is futile because there
are other parts of human nature we can
work with.
And of course that was what led to my
more recent book,
the better angels of our nature.
That said,
not only is it possible it's happened.
Yeah,
I bet.
Again,
it's kind of the nexus between the
political on the one hand and the
scientific on the other that I was
exploring.
And I talked about how the people who
thought they were advocates of peace
tried to squash all evidence that people
have a violent,
uh,
impulses because it was just politically
too uncomfortable.
And I said,
that's first of all,
distorting the science is never a good
idea.
And is it clear about the politics then
the science doesn't even mean that we've
got to accept war.
Yeah.
So for someone that's sort of insulated
themselves from some of this,
because you were doing the work
beforehand,
which is actually pretty brilliant
tactic.
Are you afraid that the hard sciences
are going to be hit by all of this
identity politics stuff in a bigger way
than we're seeing right now when it
comes to gender or race or,
or any of these issues?
It's not even so much the hard sciences,
but the social sciences,
well we know the social science happen
hit,
but you don't fear that it's going to
come from the hard sciences to,
well,
that there may be some aspects of
genetics and brain science that are,
uh,
that are feeling the political pressure,
the neuroscience of sex differences,
for example.
Um,
certainly the genetics of intelligence
and personality have a,
have felt that political pressure.
Yeah.
Uh,
a,
um,
one of my collaborators and former
students.
So James Lee presented a paper where
he's part of the consortium that for the
first time identified number of genes
that were linked to intelligence.
I mean there's no icu gene,
but there are hundreds,
probably thousands of genes that could
bump your icu up by a fraction of a
point up or down.
And they have been some of the first
really hard replicable discoveries
because there are a lot of bogus
discoveries in the past.
But this was really solid and there was,
there was pretty,
pretty big pushback,
including from the president of the
society saying,
this is,
this,
is this fascist,
this is unacceptable.
Um,
so there was some pushback and this was,
this was genetics.
So what do you make of the people that
focus on like race and Iq?
I,
you know,
I've had Stefan Molyneux here.
I don't know if you know who he is,
but he,
he really focuses on that.
And I wanted what I wanted to know from
him really was not necessarily why it
really not.
What do you think of this,
but why the focus on that,
that team,
to me,
that's the part I'm more concerned
about.
Yeah,
I think it's.
I think it's an excellent question and
it's one that,
uh,
that um,
torments me.
I mean,
on the one hand you could make the
argument,
well,
we should not be afraid of the truth.
And for that matter of vigorous,
a exploration of the genetics of racial
differences might show that there are no
genetic differences relevant to
personality or intelligence and that
would give races have a really decisive
blow.
But the other hand,
you never know that before you look.
So you can't count on that.
You've of course,
if you do science,
you got to be prepared for any
possibility.
There is,
I think,
a legitimate question of whether we
really should be getting to the bottom
of this.
It's an argument that actually goes back
to my old mit colleague,
Noam Chomsky way back in the 19
seventies said,
uh,
we can't insist that the truth one way
or another because that's just contrary
to the whole spirit of science.
But we don't have to ask every question,
a lot of questions that are
scientifically pretty minor,
they could have socially damaging
consequences.
So let's put them really low on the list
and he suggested that,
uh,
that racing Iq,
for example,
is,
should not be an interest in a society
that treats people as individuals
because then it's just like a
correlation between any two traits and
that,
uh,
that we should just be a low priority
and something that we should ignore.
Now that's a little bit.
Um,
uh,
I think it ignores the fact that there
are people who already are dividing
humans by race and by measuring the
outcomes and attributing it to poverty
or racism.
And then you kind of say,
well,
Gee,
if,
as long as we were raising the question
at all,
should we look at all the hypotheses,
it might even be an argument for just
downplaying race in general.
Uh,
instead of dividing us up by race and
obsessive measuring the differences,
I'm looking at things like class and
income because that that's really what,
what matters more and just not make
everything a racial issue in the first
place so that whether the racial issue
is from biology kind of fades and
importance.
Yeah.
You mentioned the nexus of politics and
science.
I really like that phrase because I
think there's so many of the
conversations I'm having here.
It seems to me that politics and science
are really just linked all the time and
it explains why so many people want to
talk to you and why they want to talk to
the Weinstein brothers and Sam Harris
and so many other people.
Are you a little concerned that it's
becoming so political?
Yeah,
I mean,
part of it is that it's that what,
what,
uh,
what I'm doing and what some of the
other your other guests have been doing
is to try to depoliticize some of the
scientific issues and certainly what I
tried to do in the blank slate or
clarify what the political issues are
not.
It's almost impossible these days right.
It,
it is becoming a little bit,
uh,
well,
it's,
the landscape is really diverse and
divided.
I mean there are the very,
the identity politicians in the social
justice warriors and the political
correctness police who are making things
as political as possible.
I mean they'd been around for a long
time when I was a student in the
seventies,
there were plenty of people who are
shouting things like fascists don't have
the right to speak or chanting mobs that
shut down a Harvard colleague,
Eo Wilson when he published
sociobiology.
So this isn't a new thing.
Uh,
and there are certainly constituencies
that are totally opened to
depoliticizing the science and
considering the politics on its own
terms.
But on the other hand,
there is a fringe that appears to be
more radical than ever.
Yeah.
How do you decide how much weight that
fringe has?
That seems to be one of the themes these
days.
It seems to be very hard to tell.
Is this just this small group that's
screaming a lot or,
or has it truly infected?
Not only a ton of,
you know,
the millennial generation and had a huge
swath of young people,
but that also it does seem to be
creeping up or creeping down depending
on which way you look at it.
A ton of academics at universities and
all sorts of,
all sorts of other people that actually
have power.
Well,
I think the academics have been
distorted for quite some time.
Uh,
and this is a,
a,
an idea that's been pushed by Jonathan
Heit tetlock.
Jose Duarte.
I'm sure a lot of stern.
They had a,
a pretty widely discussed article that,
uh,
the title,
something like viewpoint diversity will
help social science with a,
gave a number of cases,
some of which I had discussed in the
blank slate of how just the questions
that a psychologist ask the,
the items they put on their
questionnaires,
the way they frame issues just clearly
has a left wing bias that they argued
that if there were also people,
conservatives in more of them in psych
departments than they would have pointed
out,
Hey,
your questionnaire is flawed and that
the actual quality of the science would
improved.
And to the credit of my field of
psychology,
there are paper was published in a
journal where there are 30 commentaries,
so 30 people had a chance to go after
them or teams.
And it was,
it was,
there was disagreement,
but was very respectful.
They weren't call any nasty names and it
was a really good debate.
Um,
but the,
the question that you asked about how is
this,
uh,
are the,
the,
uh,
totally illiberal and radical movements,
the ones that just shouting down
speakers sometimes physically assault
them.
Is that the whole millennial generation
or is that just a increasingly vocal
fringe?
Uh,
my,
my mind was changed just a couple of
days ago when I read an article in vox
about a new study,
a Sam Harris had center to me saying
that actually support for free speech is
increasing,
including the article you saw the
article so that,
you know,
that I wasn't,
I was kind of surprised.
I wasn't totally shocked because at
least my experience at Harvard is that
the students are,
uh,
all the ones that I've interacted with,
admittedly a biased sample,
but they are perfectly supportive of
debate,
free speech,
openness.
So it's interesting.
So I,
I mentioned,
uh,
right before we started that I spoke at
Harvard through the open issues,
right.
And it was a wonderful group and I,
and it was clear that they were
politically diverse and,
and all the other diversity that
everyone likes,
but that I don't care about that much.
But,
uh,
afterwards we went to a dinner and there
were about 30 or 40 kids.
I was with Bret Weinstein actually.
And uh,
I asked them like,
what do you guys do?
Are you guys okay with saying what you
think and do you think it's going to
hurt your grades or hurt your
friendship?
And virtually everyone said yes.
So I'm still struggling with this
because I did read it.
They said,
they said yeah,
we would either hurt them or they've
lost friends.
Mostly I sent,
most of them were kind of libertarian
ish,
kind of live and let live.
But,
but certainly not all of them,
but,
but virtually everyone at the table said
that they either were afraid to say
certain things,
friends or certainly two professors.
So that's why when I read the articles
like that at box and I go to these
campuses and I hear this consistently,
it's just hard to grade and I,
and that's exactly why I'm posing the
question to you.
Yeah.
It's just hard to pin this article was
a,
was an eye opening.
They go,
went against the narrative that the
millennial generation,
are they a bunch of snowflakes that a
bunch of,
of,
of uh,
cultural revolutionaries,
warriors.
Uh,
it's just,
uh,
there certainly is that faction,
but it may not,
uh,
characterize our,
our era altogether.
Yeah.
Have you thought at all about how much
social media is a piece of this puzzle?
Well,
I don't know.
And that's,
you know,
nowadays everything is blamed on social
media,
kind of like,
you know,
what the role of El Nino and then nine
slash 11 happened.
I believe it.
That was all my space.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
I don't know.
A lot of this I think,
predated social media.
I think that,
uh,
a cable news networks had,
had a role,
um,
Fox News in particular because it was so
politicized,
uh,
in a way that no previous network really
had been.
And there are studies showing that when
a town gets Fox News and you could do
the natural experiment because some
towns got it before others just because
of the way cable companies offered
different packages for no particular
reason.
Uh,
you could tell the towns that got Fox
News became more polarized and became a
and shifted to the right.
So it really did have a causal effect.
That's one case where it's not just
correlational.
Yeah.
So you,
you had a strange,
a moment about a month or two ago,
about two months ago now,
were you,
you said something to the effect of you
when someone asks you a question at a
panel about the alt right and in and in
effect you said,
but I don't want to put words in mouth.
What,
what,
what did you say?
Well,
this was,
I don't want to butcher open campus
initiative.
Oh,
it was it.
They were the ones that are.
Okay.
There you go.
So I know this is a good group of people
you were sitting with.
It wasn't the.
And the,
uh,
topic of the event was,
did political correctness help elect
trump?
It was held almost on the anniversary of
the,
uh,
16 election.
And uh,
I suggest that I thought it did in part
because the,
uh,
when you have certain ideas that are
just not discussable,
uh,
on,
on campus,
and you've got a savvy,
interconnected community as the
original.
All right,
where a lot of people associate alt
right with the torch carrying skinheads.
But what I had in mind was the,
the term as it originally applied to
internet discussion groups.
Uh,
and that,
uh,
the,
the danger of restricting debate on a
campus of,
of making certain ideas taboo is that
when smart people do stumble upon them,
then they are,
number one,
are a completely alienated from the
mainstream intellectual life because
they think,
well,
this is a truth that they can't handle a
what other truths can't they?
Uh,
and they,
since the ideas never get the kind of
push back and contextualize nation and
counter-arguments kind of thing that
you,
that you want for any idea never
happens.
And within this likeminded community
they sometimes jump to the most extreme
conclusions because it's sort of a self,
a self fulfilling prophecy of sewers.
Yeah.
So an example being gender differences,
if it's taboo even to mention the
possibility that men and women differ,
then you stumble across some pretty good
scientific evidence that they do a,
then you might be like,
you know,
Milo Yiannopoulos saying,
oh,
we should,
uh,
have fewer women in medical school
because they just going to drop out and
have babies.
Now,
I mean,
that's a totally idiotic idea.
Um,
but the reason that,
that he could put forward an idiotic
idea is that since the whole existence
of sex differences never discussed,
no one ever said that's an idiotic idea.
And likewise,
and there are a number of other facts
that are kind of undiscussable that you
can take to extreme conclusions if
you're not challenged.
Whereas if you bring them out into the
open,
then you can put them into perspective.
Sunlight is the best disinfectant and in
many cases it is.
Another example is that the rates of
crime differ between blacks and whites.
Now,
if that's a fact that's almost
undiscussable,
but just go to FBI.gov.
look up.
They break down rates of a of a crime by
age,
by race,
by state,
and you know there it is.
Now,
if you have never even noticed that,
then you can say,
Oh gee,
I wonder if you know African Americans
are innately more violent than white.
That's completely wrong because we know
that no two ethnic groups ever have the
same crime rate and they can shift over
time.
It used to be the Irish that were the
that had sky high rates of violence
compared to a non Irish and we know that
that vanished over time and the black
white differences might as well,
but that second fact,
namely ethnic and racial differences are
ubiquitous and they can change with
time.
We'll never even get mentioned if the
mere fact that there is a difference is
unmentionable in the first place.
So that was my argument.
I gave some other examples anyway,
that was,
um,
then there's a doctored film clip on
some outright sites saying,
oh,
see pinker's saying that the operators
is correct.
That is actually saying,
how can we,
how can we starve the offer right now?
We're,
we're,
uh,
we're feeding them inadvertently.
You were basically,
I mean,
just for the layman that's watching
this.
I mean,
you were basically saying allow for more
information so that those bad ideas
won't be able to flourish.
I mean,
that is sort of one o one version.
That was the whole point.
Exactly.
Then it was,
it was,
uh,
edited to leave out that parts and then
the kind of regressive left picked up on
it to,
to also suggest that I was sympathetic
to the alt right,
which is most bizarre attribution you
could imagine.
And indeed,
enlightenment now has a whole chapter on
why the,
uh,
the alt right is,
um,
it has gone off the off the rails.
Unfortunately,
this misconception after a couple of
days after the day was corrected,
both in the New York Times and the
Guardian in England,
I may.
They came to my defense and set things
right,
but it wasn't bizarre.
A episode of how has the Times putting
social media makes you stupid.
Precisely.
All right,
so I do want to spend our whole second.
Okay.
Talking about the book,
but very quickly just when you dealt
with that whole thing.
I mean I remember reading it and I think
there was something in an odd way.
I think the reaction between,
as you said,
the regressive left and the right,
that they were sort of teaming up on
you.
Again.
I thought it was in a weird way,
even though I know it probably
personally for you is no fun and you
probably had all sorts of people saying
terrible things to you and all,
all of that.
That I thought if anyone has read any of
Stephen's books or even remotely knows
what this guy is doing that I think I
don't know what you consider yourself
politically.
You strike me as sort of an old school
liberal.
I don't want to,
I'm putting out there that if you
centrist moderate,
I have,
I have sympathies to different policies
and uh,
but yeah,
I'm,
I'm pretty eclectic and centrist.
Yeah.
So that,
that basically I thought this guy,
so obviously just decent and coming at
this from a,
from a scientific perspective that if
this is what they're going to do,
where at,
where you say one line,
this is going to destroy.
I mean really my feeling was he could
destroy,
like the fabric of society really if we
just start picking off everybody and
I've seen a lot of instances of this and
this,
you know,
when I've talked to when I've talked to
or I've talked to Bret Weinstein or
Lindsay Shepherd from Lori a up in
Canada and a few others that they.
But I thought yours was just such an
example of this is so ridiculous as
well.
So perhaps there was a nice push back to
it maybe.
And that was,
that was exactly the New York Times
response.
I mean,
that's why they titled the op Ed.
Um,
by that Jesse Singal,
how social media makes them stupid.
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's talk about the book right here in
front of me.
Enlightenment.
Now I've been kicking around this phrase
on twitter that's called a little
traction that we are now in the
enlightened because it seems like we're
in this endless stream of constant
stupidity and I,
and some of it seems social media
related and we touched a little bit on
that in part one.
And when I'm saying it,
I'm saying it a little tongue in cheek
and actually this book is sort of the
answer to I think what I'm calling the
enlightenment that there are so many
good things happening right now and it,
and it's very hopeful and optimistic.
And I always tell people I'm an
optimist,
otherwise I couldn't do this.
You know what I mean?
I,
I feel that there's a chance we can make
things better.
So first off,
let's just do some one on one stuff.
You're,
what our enlightenment values to you.
Well,
I,
I characterize them in the subtitle of
book as reason science humanism and
progress reason that we should,
uh,
analyze our situation,
our predicament,
a using the most rigorous a logic that
we can.
And rather than relying on dogma,
authority,
tradition,
scripture,
I'm not going for social media advocacy,
social media,
although at least throwing ideas out
there as long as they get evaluated,
as long as they had criticized,
I'm a science,
that namely that we should test our
hypotheses,
seat deep explanations and that science
provides us not just with a gadgets and
cures for disease,
although it's important that it does
that,
but also defines our,
our human condition,
that concepts from science,
like evolution,
like entropy,
like the whole naturalistic world view,
that the laws of nature do their thing
without caring about us.
These are things that we have to
understand as the most basic facts about
our existence.
So science is has to be part of our
world to you.
Then humanism is the idea that it's
human beings and other sentient animals
that deserve our,
our our moral concern as opposed to they
say the glory of the tribe or following
a caring it,
religious dictates or the faith or some
messianic age that it's just,
do people live long,
healthy,
happy,
stimulating lives.
That's what we should care about.
And then progress is that if we use
reason and science to make people better
off,
well maybe we can gradually succeed.
Yeah.
So it's funny when I,
when I was reading this and the only
word that like dinged a little something
in my head was progress.
And I think it's partly because of the
way progressives have used progress that
progress in and of itself.
You want to progress meeting have more
and more opportunity for people more and
more equality for people.
I think that's a far cry from what I
think the progressive's are doing right
now because that's the most subjective
one of any of those terms.
Right?
Well,
I,
I have the wisecrack that progressives
hate progress.
If you look at the people who denied
that we've made progress,
it's often the people who politically
labeled themselves as progressive who
can't stand the idea that we've made
progress because they wanted to save it.
Every aspect of our current society and
institutions.
There's corrupt and racist and
controlled by the,
by the one percent and everything is
getting worse and worse and worse.
And ironically,
because the whole point of being a
progressive presumably is that
progressive activism is not a waste of
time,
but it actually brings benefits and
which,
which actually has it sort of the catch
22 of,
of progress in general that you have to
acknowledge it,
but in a weird way,
you need to not acknowledge it to keep
furthering it.
Yeah.
So there is an optimum amount and what
it has to keep in mind the two ideas
that we've made progress.
But we've got huge challenges ahead of
us.
Just a very simple example,
a extreme poverty,
the bare minimum that you,
that you need to feed your family,
uh,
has been,
has been falling.
And that's it.
It's got to be an example of progress in
a couple of hundred years ago,
you could say that probably 90 percent
of humanity was living in extreme
poverty.
Now it's less than 10 percent.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
A lot of that happened just in the last
30 years.
Um,
but another way of stating the same fact
is that 730 million people live in
extreme poverty.
Now that's the same fact,
10 percent of seven point 3 billion,
730 million,
that's an awful lot of miserable people.
Now those are the same described in two
different ways and we got to be able to
think in both ways and let's,
let's try to get it to zero now.
That's not a crazy romantic utopian
story eyed a goal that is one of the UN
sustainable development goals.
The predecessor,
the Millennium Development Goals for
poverty was reached five years ahead of
schedule.
So the new goal,
which is to eliminate extreme poverty
everywhere by 20,
30,
probably a little too optimistic,
but uh,
but not,
not completely crazy,
and maybe it'll be instead of zero
percent,
maybe it will be two percent and maybe
it'll be 20,
40,
but still it's an amazing,
uh,
aspiration in the first place.
How much of this do you think,
and it's a little bit,
gets back to the blank slate,
but how much of this do you think the
way you view progress,
whether the acknowledgement of progress
or that you sort of need to feel that
we've made no progress to kind of fuel
yourself?
How much of that do you think is just
hardwired in the way we look at the
world?
I think some of it comes from a certain
cognitive biases.
One of them being the availability
heuristic being discovered by Daniel
Kahneman and Amos Tversky,
namely the human mind generally
estimates,
probability and risk by calling examples
from memory.
If you've just seen a,
a tornado on the news,
then you think that tornadoes are a
major cause of death and the fact that
you know,
falls off ladders,
killed many more people than tornadoes.
It doesn't register because those don't
make the news.
Uh,
and,
and we,
we don't naturally calibrate for how
many opportunities there are for bad
things to happen,
how big the world is,
how many people there are,
we just remember the examples and that's
what drives our intuitions.
And when you have the news media
reporting,
everything that goes wrong everywhere,
then you can come away with an
impression that the world is falling
apart because all the parts of the world
that aren't falling apart just never
make the news.
So that's one.
There is also a,
uh,
we,
we are,
I think tuned to dwell on the negative
probably because bad things can hurt you
a lot more than good things can help
you.
So there is something adaptive in a
natural environment to be on the lookout
for,
for what can kill you.
So that's just a survival instinct.
That's,
I think,
part of the survival instinct there.
There are other things too,
like the,
uh,
there's always implicit competition
between different elites in society,
the academics,
the journalists,
the politicians,
the business people that religious,
the military,
you know,
they're all different kinds of power
centers and they all kind of compete
with each other for prestige and a,
and an influence.
And if you say society is declining,
it's corrupt,
it's a mess.
It's horrible.
It's kind of a way of,
uh,
each one of these groups can kind of
feel superior to the others.
The academics could say,
look what the businessmen in the
country,
in a business when you can say,
look what the politicians are doing to
the country.
And the challenges can say,
look,
the incumbents are doing.
And so it's kind of a backhanded way of
social oneupmanship do you sense that
right now we're at a unique position to
bring back more enlightenment values?
Like it seems to me that because of
trump,
because of social media,
that just everything is sort of upside
down right now.
This again has been a theme with a bunch
of my guests that everything is sort of
on the table and that there's great
opportunity.
We don't know which way it's going to
go,
but there's great opportunity for good
ideas.
There's a great opportunity for bad
Obviously.
I know which way we're both hoping this
is going to be.
Yes.
But do you think that we actually are in
a unique moment right now?
I know everyone always thinks that
they're always going to be there.
They're always in the moment.
Right?
But do you think there's something
unique right now?
Well,
it's,
there's someone thinking that there's
kind of any quality of every reason
maybe growing that at the top.
There's so many areas in which we become
so much more rational and reasonable,
uh,
like evidence based medicine used to be
your doctor had a hunch and operated on,
you gave her your drug and there's no
reason to think that we're actually
working.
Now therapies are evaluated in a big
studies or a data driven policing.
One of the reasons that the crime rate
went down so dramatically starting in
the nineties is that the police started
to gather block by block data and where
the violence was occurring,
they kind of collapsed on those areas
like a ton of bricks.
Make sure that,
uh,
one gang member that just suffered a,
a,
uh,
an injury wouldn't be roaring for
revenge saying,
you know,
we were watching you and that really
drove down the rate of crime by a lot in
sports.
I'm a sabermetrics moneyball,
much more rational analysis.
Uh,
you know,
there's the effective altruism movement.
How can we allocate charity and
volunteering so it actually does good as
opposed to just giving people a warm
glow.
And so all of these areas,
but at the same time,
you get these not all conspiracy
theories and the fake news and be a
politicized denial of science such as
vaccine safety and climate change.
So the question is,
how do we let the standards of
rationality,
hitches will trickle down,
make it so that,
uh,
that it's kind of second nature for
everyone to just not think in certain
ways because they had just been proven
to be obviously ridiculous.
Yeah.
How do you do it?
I mean,
I think that's a good.
So I may not be the one to,
uh,
you know,
to,
to change a whole society.
I do it by appealing to the kind of
people who watch the show,
kind of people would read my books in
the hopes that it will kind of spread
out from there.
And we know it's not.
No,
it's not that it can't happen there.
There are certain bad ideas that at one
point are taken seriously and then they
just drop off.
And like,
no one talks about when ever,
again,
in my lifetime when I was a kid,
there was a debate over racial
segregation,
you know,
should,
should black students be admitted to the
University of Mississippi.
I mean,
you just couldn't have that debate
anymore.
Even among the,
the farthest right of the right.
That's just no longer an issue should
women be allowed to,
to,
to work.
Um,
and uh,
in earlier decades and centuries it was
slavery or women's suffrage and
superstitions like,
uh,
you know,
alchemy a or a human sacrifice.
So it's not hopeless that sometimes what
happens is that at any given time
there's a range of reasonableness,
but that,
that center drifts.
So that some things that were at the
tail end of,
of,
of ridiculousness,
even the conspiracy theory mongers and
the most benighted can no longer take it
seriously.
Yeah.
How would you,
this is just sort of are.
Or the discussion around all this is
just about our lack of patience.
Because actually when the,
when the publisher sent me the book,
I said Enlightenment now.
And as you think you guys had the.
And now he's bigger than enlightenment
and I thought that was kind of
interesting because we live in a time of
immediate reaction to everything and
selfies and likes and people just don't
have patience anymore.
Attention spans are,
are incredibly short that we want more
now.
But some of these things are just the
long game.
Yeah,
I think that's it.
That's exactly right.
We also,
we have Amnesia for how things were not
so long ago.
Yeah,
that's a point that I make a uh,
repeatedly,
even though there are,
you know,
there's a horrific war going on now in
Syria,
but we forget some of the horrific wars
that were going on in the,
uh,
in the eighties and nineties.
What can we do to stop that Amnesia?
Because I think that's a big part of
this.
Yeah.
And I think the culture of journalism
should,
should put events of the day into some
context.
I don't mean going back hundreds of
years,
the American revolution,
but even just,
you know,
what was like in the 19 nineties was
likely the eighties,
the likewise we'll be economy.
People are so nostalgic for the early
areas with strong unions and predictable
wages and factory jobs,
but you know,
that was also the era of a double digit
inflation.
Eighteen percent inflation.
If you could pay the rent this year,
you didn't know whether you could pay it
next year because rick could go up and
kind of forget about those days long.
A lines around the block that had
gasoline for fear that we'd run out of
heating oil and fuel freeze in the
winter.
A huge high rates of poverty among the
elderly.
People that have been has been brought
down by social security,
so our just.
Our commentary should look back.
They're not ancient history,
but recent history.
Yeah.
What are some of the other things that
are that are hopeful right now?
Are there other markers in society or in
science or politics?
Are there any other trends that you're
seeing right now that you think are
leading us to some positive places?
Well,
often you get pleasant surprises when
you actually look at trends instead of
headlines,
and you and I were talking off camera
about a,
a,
a recent survey that showed that
contrary to the fears of a millennial
generation being intolerant of free
speech and the rep for that matter,
the society as a whole,
and especially university campuses,
they actually,
according to this new study anyway,
you actually plot the data.
We asked people should people who are
espousing controversial beliefs at least
be able to say them.
It's actually been going up.
Uh,
it's higher among the college educated
than the less college educated.
It spans a range of controversial
positions.
It's true for millennials as well as
baby boomers.
And so the,
what I,
myself even experienced as a kind of
dread and foreboding about a whole
generation being intolerant of competing
views,
it turns out to be probably overblown.
There are a lot of examples like that
and the other positive developments,
I mean,
the,
the high school students protesting are
ridiculous,
gun safety laws,
that kind of something that we couldn't
have predicted.
Uh,
so recently the,
the me too movement has had a lot of
excesses and you know,
I think there's much to criticize.
On the other hand,
it's not okay for women to be preyed
upon by their bosses and that is
suddenly becoming an issue and probably
the society will on the whole change for
the better because of it.
I wasn't planning on going here,
but since you mentioned it,
what would be a humanistic,
enlightened way of looking at guns right
now?
Oh yeah.
Well,
some of it a lot.
It has to start with,
with good data because a lot of our
stereotypes of,
uh,
just,
you know,
maybe right,
maybe wrong on the right,
they believe you have concealed carry
laws then that will reduce crime on the
left.
There is if we control guns,
that will reduce a homicide.
So we've got to be humble and try to get
as many studies as possible to know what
will really make a difference in what
won't.
But in general,
the idea that,
uh,
that we're,
we're better off if we're,
we individually are not the,
uh,
you're kind of judged,
jury,
jury and executioner,
that one of the great advances of
civilization was that you outsource
justice to a disinterested third party
named with the court system.
And that the idea that safety comes from
individuals defending their interests
with guns is,
will in fact almost certainly has led to
high rates of violence.
Do you fear though that we could,
that we often give too much power to the
state?
I mean,
I think in,
in,
in some areas we do,
but I think the idea that people should
have guns so that they should resist the
uh,
the government,
you know,
the kind of David Koresh and Idaho a
cults,
that is a terrible idea.
The idea that we should resist the
government with,
with guns.
I mean,
that's what they do in Congo,
Somalia,
we have this thing called democracy.
So if the government becomes too
repressive,
we speak out against it.
We vote,
we petition,
I,
we form organizations.
But the idea that we're going to shoot
back at the police,
I mean,
that's nuts.
What do you think of the state of our
democracy in general?
Because I think we're breaking off into
these different factions now where,
I mean,
I think some people genuinely think
that,
you know,
this hashtag resistance,
that we're under this horrific
authoritarian regime with.
We don't even have to get into trump
specifically if you don't want,
but what do you think of just sort of
the,
the systems that are in place,
the branches of government,
all of the documents that founded this
or are they doing all right at the
moment?
So,
so there are a lot of,
uh,
by any standards of world history,
we live in fantastic freedom.
Know I could say that,
uh,
you know,
trump is a moron and he's a fascist and
I don't have to worry about being put in
jail.
I mean,
that's a real.
Something to take,
not to take for granted.
If I sent the equivalent in Turkey,
I wouldn't be put in jail or in,
in,
in Venezuela.
Is that a little bit of the short memory
on some of these things and why you need
to know history?
Because I think that all the time I see
these guys all over twitter medians.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
You can say what ever you really can and
we should not take that for granted.
It's apartment history,
but also partly a comparisons across
countries.
And then history remembering fascism and
communism and looking at regions today
like,
like Turkey and Venezuela and Russia.
There's that.
It,
the,
what's not so healthy is like
gerrymandering that obviously super a
subversion of democracy,
uh,
the effects of lobbying and campaign
contributions from the,
the,
the wealthiest.
That can't be a good idea.
The fact that our elections drag on for
a year and depends so much on,
on a cash is a problem.
Um,
and there are government bureaucracies
that have gotten too big and too,
too many regulations that don't actually
do anything beneficial.
I don't think that means that's called
for just reducing regulation with,
uh,
with,
a meat cleaver because some regulations
really have done,
done good.
We've got cleaner air,
we've got less poverty.
Uh,
but we should at least analyze what
government programs,
uh,
are,
are cost effective and which ones are
just a nuisance and a drag.
Yeah.
And even having that conversation then
gets people crazy where I,
I personally,
I come from it from a little more of a
libertarian perspective and I would
usually say that these days we've got
people like Elon Musk that can get us to
Mars and that can help clean the
environment and green energy and all of
those things where I know there's just
another set of people that think,
well,
we just can't leave it to the
industrialists.
We have to leave it to the government.
That's at least a place where we can
have some respectful disagreement that's
a,
that's a great place to.
That's the conversation we should be
having.
And I,
uh,
my,
my view is that there has to be a mix of
a policy and regulation and a private
enterprise I and with all of the
creativity and,
and bottom up a diversity that.
So an example would be one thing that
the government can do and that private
industry can do is put a price on carbon
emissions and this is a,
a position that both left wing and right
wing economists favor.
But having done that,
then the private sector can come up with
a technology to reduce CO2 and it
shouldn't be up to the government to say
this,
this company is the one that we're going
to have support.
Right?
And that's where the,
the,
uh,
the free market really does a better
job.
But having that,
that discussion,
and I think Libertarians deserve credit
for raising an issue that people on the
left just don't even think of.
Like just because you have good
intentions and you have a program with
the goal of achieving some good doesn't
mean it's gonna work.
Total waste of money.
Well that's what I think so much of it
is.
It sounds good.
It all sounds good.
We want the government to do all these
things and then we know that in practice
often,
although you've laid out a case for some
of these things that actually do work
cleaner air here,
I mean look,
we're in Los Angeles and air is cleaner
and it really,
it had a lot to do with the government
for sure.
So I absolutely acknowledge that,
but to me it seems like so much of it
feels like it's.
It sounds good.
Let's just sort of hand it to the
government.
Yeah.
And then you end up creating a whole
series of other problems that are from
fiscal things to,
to all sorts of other things.
Yeah,
and I agree and I think actually in some
ways liberals had been their own worst
enemy and not being willing to have that
conversation and almost like the
platform is,
if you support government programs,
you're a good person and if you post
them,
you're a bad person.
Whereas the,
the,
the discussion really should be which
government programs make us better off,
repay their costs to clean up the air,
reduce poverty,
which ones are,
you know,
boondoggles are bureaucracies and that
way even the people who are liberals
could at least have some ammunition and
say,
well,
don't,
don't kill that program.
It actually works.
And I have in the book a graph of the
environmental quality since the EPA was
initiated in 1970 by Richard Nixon.
As it turns out,
and the population has increased by 40
percent GDP increased by two and a half.
Uh,
we've driven twice as many miles,
but air pollution has been reduced by 60
percent.
So,
and that,
that almost certainly wouldn't have just
happened with market innovation because
there's just no,
no one individually has an incentive to
not pollute.
That's the kind of thing where
governments can make a difference.
Likewise,
I'm a poverty or there are certain
measures like the earned income tax
credit,
which is a kind of negative income tax
where almost everyone who a right and
left two exams.
So that's a government program that
really worked.
It's kind of cheap.
So automatic and it really did reduce
poverty and the lower middle class and
working poor and we need to have that
discussion so that the liberals for that
matter can say,
well,
this,
this program works.
Don't cut it.
They don't pay.
But even they have kind of disarmed on
the often on the evidentiary a debate
and just made it more realistic.
Yeah.
I think that's what so many of us that I
would include in this new group.
Have you heard this phrase,
intellectual dark web?
Has this,
has this come across your desk?
I googled it.
I mean,
do you sort of catch what I mean?
I think that,
I don't know who's to say what it is or
who is in it or whatever,
but it strikes me that you were sort of
one of the people that's right there.
Just people that are all coming together
because we're just trying to get a
little bit of the answers here,
which really is what this is about.
Yeah.
And um,
the way Jonathan Haidt calls it,
his viewpoint diversity,
that it's,
uh,
it's not pushing a particular ideology,
but it's getting a set of ideas out
there that,
that they have to,
they have,
they have to struggle.
They don't,
they don't get a pass.
The whole point of,
of mentioning them is that,
okay,
now now attack them,
see if they survive.
Is there a piece of America right now or
I guess we can say this in the West in
general,
that our freedoms have gotten so good
actually,
that we can't really figure out what's
bad.
So for example,
like during the,
uh,
the whole debate over the football
players kneeling for the anthem,
I was watching people and everyone's
just screaming about everything.
And half the people hate trump.
Half the people say the football players
are anti American and half the people
turn it on the owners of the teams.
But I tried to lay out a case that
actually the entire thing worked the way
it was supposed to do in a free society.
Trump said something,
but he didn't.
Whether you agree with what he said or
not about mocking the players,
he didn't try to pass a law about it,
so he has so he exercises his free
speech.
It's important to recognize that that he
has that right to.
If he had tried to pass a law,
that's a different thing.
The players could either neil or not
neil,
they might have to deal with the
repercussions of that.
The owners could decide whether they
want it to keep those players on.
Their teams are not.
The fans could decide if they want it to
not buy jerseys or not or not attend
games.
Right.
That to me it was actually like a puzzle
of freedom actually working and yet
every day for months people were
screaming that this is,
you know,
that this is tyrannical regime and
everything so horrible.
Does that sort of jive with you that,
that we've gotten to a place where we
don't.
Our freedoms are so great that we're
making these,
these mountains out of things that are
important to talk about,
but yeah,
I think that's a good.
That's good analysis.
I mean,
I think it's a way of appreciating what
other countries would would die for.
I mean,
you just couldn't have that football
players or soccer players and the here
in Turkey protests,
government policy.
I mean they,
they'd be in jail.
Turkey,
one of our ally,
you know,
ally,
it depends how you want to use air
quotes.
Yeah.
But yes,
I guess I think sort of a good point.
Yeah.
So before we finish up here,
give me it.
Give me a few more things to just feel
hopeful about because I think that
really is what you're,
you're trying to show people that
there's so much goodness right now and
let's not lose that.
Yeah.
Well,
here's some,
some,
uh,
heartening facts.
They have the flynn effect that Iq
scores have been rising by three points
a decade for almost a century.
A something here.
I know.
Incredible as it may sound really well.
I'm going to have to dive into that one
a little bit.
I spent much time on twitter.
Uh,
certainly the fact that extreme poverty
has been plummeting,
I think is one of the greatest things
that's ever happened to me,
literally from 75 percent reduction just
in 30 years in global rate of extreme
poverty and the rise of,
of literacy,
90 percent of the world's population
under the age of 25 can read and write
and there's almost perfect parody now
between girls and boys,
but that's encouraging diseases.
Infectious diseases are in decline.
Um,
malaria,
tuberculosis,
diarrhea,
and uh,
we vanquish smallpox just sent it off
into the,
the,
uh,
in,
into ancient history.
It's no longer a disease there.
We may do the same thing with polio with
Guinea worm is terrific progress being
made.
Um,
the uh,
and values of toleration.
And,
um,
what would I think we'd all agree,
or progressive values such as a
toleration of homosexuality,
of women's equality,
have the right to get a divorce of
political participation.
Uh,
those have,
believe it or not,
all been in Ge in a gradual increase in
every part of the world,
even in the most politically backward
part of the world.
Namely,
the Middle East and North Africa,
there's been an increase with,
especially when you compare generations
with the younger generations are much
more,
uh,
open and uh,
I'm sympathetic to liberal values than
the older generation and there's a,
a,
a widespread illusion.
Everyone thinks that everyone else is
more reactionary than they really are.
Uh,
people say,
well,
I'm kind of progressive,
but everyone around me reactionaries
there's a huge gap in how tolerant
people really are and in how tolerant
they think everyone else's.
And that's really interesting.
All right,
so,
so in summation,
we should feel good about the future,
but we have to fight for it,
right?
We should be recognized.
What we're in danger of losing.
We should recognize what we've
accomplished as a kind of a impetus to
do more steven pinker,
it's been an absolute pleasure.
Thank you for doing remind.
Thanks for having me.
And for more on Steven,
check out his new book enlightenment.
Now the case for reasons science,
humanism and progress,
which we've linked to write down below.